Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get to the e-mail mailbag for the week.
If you have something to say and you feel
like it's worth me checking it out, you can
email info at David Pakman dot com.
Sometimes we will grab a YouTube comment here
or there or a Twitter reply or a Facebook
post or whatever the case may be.
But not this week.
This week it is all bona fide emails, the
first coming from Chris.
In fact, I received a number of beautiful
messages and some trolling about my COVID
illness which spread through the house like
a virus which it is.
Last week Chris said, Sorry to hear about
your COVID illness.
I hope you get better soon and have no long
COVID effects.
I got it back in August for the first time
and luckily my sickness wasn't too bad other
than a headache for a day.
Thanks for everything you do and I wish you
the best for you and your family.
Yes, I had it worse than a headache for a
day.
In fact, there was about a 28 hour period
where I was as sick as I can remember being,
and I got all sorts of different messages.
There was someone who wrote to me and said
that they put hydrogen peroxide in their throat.
Now, why am I saying it that way?
Because that's the way they wrote it.
You can see that message on my Twitter and
Instagram.
They said they put it in their throat and
then something about lemon juice.
I didn't do that.
I didn't introduce light and heat inside the
body.
I didn't use bleach or any of that stuff.
And fortunately.
Fortunately.
It wasn't as bad as it could have been.
It was pretty bad, but it wasn't as bad as
it could have been.
And I appreciate all of the messages from
everybody.
Sharon wrote in about what is a very contentious
topic and about which I have made a decision.
And I'm going to ask you to respect that decision.
You don't have to like it.
But I am going to need you to respect it.
Sharon wrote in about interruptions.
And Sharon said, I enjoy watching your show.
Often Christo evolves, has a YouTube show.
And when he shows a political clip, we see
only the clip on the screen.
You don't see my mug.
And he does not share the screen or interrupt.
Have you ever gone to see a movie with someone
and they talk or try to get your attention
during the movie?
They ruin the movie.
I lose the joy of the moment when there are
constant interruptions.
It's nerve wracking and I generally end it
before the show is over.
I so wish you would not interrupt your clips
or other featured program.
Thanks, Sharon.
So listen.
I get it.
There's two views on this.
One is, David, shut up.
Just play the clip and don't say anything.
Start to finish.
The other view is I can get the clip elsewhere.
The reason I'm watching you, David, is for
your commentary and so manage it the way you
want to manage it.
I have made the decision because no matter
what I do, people complain if we just play
clips, long clips, and I don't say anything.
A lot of people say it's not even it's like
not even really your show anymore.
You're just playing a clip.
I've made the decision, much like during live
streams, where we watch a debate or a rally.
I will opine.
I'm trying to offer something in addition
to just being a repeater of clips.
And so I completely respect people who don't
want to see me or hear from me during clips.
There are lots of clipping services and Twitter
users who will just post clips and no commentary.
I've made the decision for the show, for what
the show is, that I will use my discretion
and sometimes you'll see my face during a
clip and sometimes you will hear me say things
and I will try to strike the right balance,
as always, with peace and love.
You know, I will try to strike the right balance
and do everything that everybody wants me
to do the best possible way.
But there are going to be interruptions because
that's the format of the show.
And maybe Christo Evolves has decided on a
different format, and that's a beautiful thing.
We can all have our formats and we love you
share and that's the important thing.
We receive the commentary with absolute peace
and love.
Jason wrote it and said, I think the left
is in trouble.
Writing with the absolute disaster the Republican
Party has become, more and more people in
my social circle are voting Democrat.
Do you believe that as more people move over
to the left, that the left as a whole is in
danger of becoming more centrist?
Thanks for taking the time to read the question
and for producing amazing content.
No, I don't actually.
I just don't believe that's happening because
there's two things that are taking place here.
There are people who vote for Democrats.
Because they love the Democratic platform.
And there are people who vote for Democrats
because they find it to be the better of the
two options that have a shot at winning.
But the truth is that the Democratic electorate
is actually far more to the left of where
the elected officials are.
So it's already a very centrist, represented
party.
And because of a combination of different
factors, including the way districts are drawn
and so many different things, what I'm actually
seeing is a Democratic Party that, at least
on paper, has continued to move to the left.
Now, whether the elected officials move to
the left sort of remains to be seen still.
But I don't think that that's the case.
I also think that this is a sort of temporary
aspect where disheartened Republicans who
don't like MAGA either don't vote or vote
Democrat.
I think eventually the Democratic Party is
going to figure it out and they're going to
get away from MAGA and go back to something
else.
So I don't believe that that's going to be
an issue.
I think Democrats should take victories while
they can.
Sam wrote in about foreign pronunciations
and really is not happy with me, Sam said
on the November 29th show.
You pronounce the word Uruguay in what I assumed
to be a Spanish Spanish pronunciation, accompanied
with the phrase Uruguay.
Please, folks.
Isn't.
Isn't my audience the best?
This makes me wonder, when you were talking
to your Argentinean friends about American
or English people, do you expect your Argentinean
friends to pause their native accents and
pronounce American names, terms, phrases in
an American accent, and British names, terms
and phrases in a British accent?
That's kind of weird, but.
Or is this just an expectation you wield towards
native English speakers, for example, if you're
Argentinean friend was to say to you, I think
Donald Trump is even worse than Boris Johnson
in Spanish.
Would you expect them to use American and
British accents for the names?
Right.
Shopian.
Soak it.
Donald Trump.
A sound period killer.
Boris Johnson.
No, I would not expect them to do that.
Listen, folks, I'm doing hours and hours of
content and I will interject flavor.
And part of the flavor is Americans pronounce
Uruguay in what seem like absurd ways.
Uruguay, I've found I mean, it's come on.
So I'm just it's just a reminder of the way
that it's pronounced Uruguay.
That's all.
It's not to be offensive.
It's not to criticize anyone.
It's not because I expect Argentinean people
to do something when they say a British name.
It's just a podcast and a YouTube channel.
All right.
Let's all take it easy.
It's just a little joke.
It's sort of like when I will say my birth
city of Buenos Aires, I could pronounce it
in these mangled American ways.
Benazir's, that is Iris.
It's all sounds almost like a disease, and
it is very much not a disease, my friends.
Buenos Aires.
We're just having a good time.
All right?
Let's not take ourselves too, too seriously.
Peter wrote in, and Peter asks an important
question and says, Subscribe is free.
Yes, David, to subscribe is free.
Is that correct?
A membership costs, but to subscribe costs
nothing.
If that is so, then tell people that this
reads like a haiku.
It costs you nothing to click on subscribe.
It only indicates you affirm the show if it
costs nothing and you say that over and over
and over, you'll reach 3 million in no time.
Subscribe also tells YouTube something positive.
Is that also true?
Let people know that as well.
If I've got it right, let me know.
Peter, you have it 100% correct.
When you hit that subscribe button on YouTube,
it is free.
You are affirming the show and it does tell
YouTube something positive, which is recommend
this chaps videos to more people.
So I say to you today.
Hit that subscribe button, my friends.
It's a very, very important thing.
Steven wrote in and says, Hey, David, longtime
listener here.
Just something I thought about the other day.
Isn't Trump announcing another run kind of
like him admitting, but not admitting that
he lost in 2020?
The whole system is rigged, but also vote
for me.
If he truly believed that it was rigged, why
would he try to run again?
Thanks for the time.
So this is so great because they have answers
to all these questions and it's sort of like
a if you stupid answer, stupid, stupid questions
sort of thing you and I might say.
If you want in 2020, you can't run again because
you can't.
You can only you can only do it twice.
You can't do it three times.
They say, Well, we were the rightful winners
based on the will of the people, but they
made Biden president.
So we I still got to run.
I get to do two terms.
They figure that one out.
Next one, if it's rigged, why would people
vote if people voted in 2020 for you but they
gave it to Biden?
Wouldn't it just happen again?
Why even bother to run?
And then they say, we just need to win by
enough that they can't rig it.
Are they have an answer?
You know, whenever you think you've got them
in a logic pretzel, they always have an answer.
Ryan wrote in about gift memberships one of
my favorite topics and says, Hey, David and
Tim, I'm wondering if it's possible to gift
memberships to specific people.
I thought you mentioned it was a feature when
gift memberships were rolled out, but I could
be mistaken.
Yes.
Here, Owen.
Cheers.
And hope your daughter is feeling healthier
this week.
Yeah, she had the easiest run of the COVID.
It lasted like 24 hours.
It was crazy, actually, how quickly she.
She was doing better.
Faster than everybody.
Okay.
How to gift a membership to a specific person
you go to join Pacman dot com.
You sign up, you check that this is a gift
button.
When you complete the process, there is a
pop up and it'll say, Who do you want to send
the gift to?
You type in their name, you type in their
email.
Big Bang boom.
It is that simple, my friends.
Very, very easy, Josh wrote in about the white
paper.
David Sir, great job on the building.
Arguments without burning bridges.
White paper despite being an inherently racist
document.
That's a joke.
The paper provides valuable insights and suggestions
for engaging in good faith conversations about
difficult topics.
I look forward to referencing this document
to improve my arguments and methods.
Folks, the White Paper is available to you
for free.
You go to David Pakman dot com slash guide
David Pakman dot com slash guide.
It is free.
You type in your email address, we send you
the white paper eight or ten page document.
I should figure out how many pages it is which
contains a treasure trove.
This is an original document that we put together
on how to have conversations with people with
wacky political views.
Get them to reconsider their beliefs without
ruining the relationships.
Check it out.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
You can get instant access to the bonus show
by signing up at join Packman dot com.
Speaker 2: Thank your lucky.
Speaker 5: Stars every day.
You're not.
Speaker 1: Back.
Yeah.
Thank you.
And you can use the coupon.
Code 24 starts now to get yourself a discount.
We'll see you then.
Or otherwise.
Back here on Monday.